[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez vu passer ces
photos sur mon compte instagram
c'est moi nous préparant une sortie vélo
habillée avec mon casque
bien évidemment c'est hyper important de
venir se protéger la tête mais surtout
avec ses lunettes connectés d'un nouveau
genre
ce sont des lunettes avec de la réalité
augmentée qui vous permettent de
connaître vos performances d'avoir tout
un tas d'informations extrêmement
pertinentes à destination des sportifs
et c'est justement ces lunettes dont je
vais vous parler aujourd'hui et c'est
super cool de points vous en parler
parce que c'est une boîte française qui
est située dans le jura et cette boîte
c'est julbo alors jimbo je sais pas si
vous vous laissez ils font des lunettes
pour tous vos sport en extérieur
vraiment destiné pour les sportifs il
est sorti un produit qui est vraiment
très atypique vraiment très particulier
qui est une nouveauté
je ne viens pas tant vous en parler pour
le côté performance sportive parce que
vous vous en douterez je me déjà dit je
ne suis pas un très grand sportif
quoique je fais du vélo ça c'est très
très cool je vais vraiment vous en
parler pour côté technologique puisque
ses lunettes vous permettent de voir vos
performances je dis bien de voir
performance en temps réel alors vous
êtes en train de courir que vous êtes
sur un vélo quel que soit votre sport
dans la mesure où vous portez salut
d'être là je les allume entoure sa gelée
connecte à mon smartphone grâce à mon
application of faith heidi fonctionne
avec ses magnifiques je suis connecté
hélas pas donc je vous parle j'ai accès
à des informations je vois depuis
combien de temps il faut lancer le
chrono ça fait à peine cinq secondes
je vois que je n'ai absolument aucune
vitesse parce que je ne bouge pas je
vois qu'il me reste 43% de batteries qui
dès 14h 13e manche cette vidéo et hop je
change d'écran là je vois mon délivré et
hop je rechange d'écran et j'ai plein
d'infos j'ai accès à ses informations
directement en réalité augmentée et ça
c'est vraiment génial qui vous expliquer
comment ça marche et ses lunettes
s'appelle les évade one ce sont avant
tout des lunettes de sport qui sont
légères pour voir qu'on a un écran
intérieur pour voir contre une batterie
et qu'on a tous le système connecté moi
je trouve légères elles font à peine 35
g autant vous dire que vous donnez vous
en rendez absolument pas compte vous
avez surtout des verts qui sont adaptées
à tout type de sport en extérieur ce
sont des verts
et active photochromiques performance 1
3 koné du lbo pour la qualité de leurs
nerfs et ici ils ont vraiment mis le
paquet vous m'avez vu poser mon doigt
ici vous laissez votre doigt en position
pendant quelques secondes
eh bien ça vire et année lunettes qui
voulait c'est de la même manière en
position pendant quelques secondes
ça vient les allumés et ensuite tout se
passe ici à l'intérieur on peut deviner
l'affichage que vous avez ici tout se
passe ici au niveau de l'art est à
l'intérieur
vous avez cette partie là qui va dire
projeté contre cette partie qui a
espèces de petits miroirs en fait et qui
va venir le faire apparaître directement
aux superpositions sans vote vert donc
vous allez le voir vous à travers vos
lunettes
à noter qu'ici vous avez un écran oled
de 304 pixels par 256 pixels avec une
diagonale de 0,19 pouces et ce qui est
super et si c'est que vous avez une très
bonne luminosité très bonne lisibilité
tous vos sports extérieurs qui est
beaucoup de soleil ou pas beaucoup vous
retrouver juste ici sur le côté une
batterie de 90 millions terreur qui vous
donne une autonomie allant jusqu'à douze
heures pour certains sportifs de très
haut niveau qui vont vouloir faire des
courses elle pourquoi pas un ultra
trails arrivera un moment où vous allez
manquer de batterie mais pour le commun
des mortels mais pour faire un marathon
eh bien vous aura absolument aucun
problème
son aîné jean baud avec la qualité de
jules beau prévenir up les bouger ici
pour les adapter directement la forme de
vos oreilles plutôt bien la tenue est
cool et surtout ce qui est très
impressionnant ici je sais j'ai ça fait
une drôle de tête mais parce que je suis
pas en train de faire du sport est en
fait le truc est vraiment super avec ça
et bien c'est que elles sont vraiment
légère pour voir qu'on a quand même
toute cette partie là avec cet écran ici
c'est léger sur la tête on le sent
quasiment pas au rendre plus en détails
du fabricant de lunettes que du
passionné de teck la regarder la
voudrait même ici là des aérations qui
ont été mises en place pour vous n'ayez
aucune but et lors de vos différents
efforts ça plutôt malin plutôt malin
très malin mais j'aurais adoré pouvoir
vous emmener sur des chemins nous
balader partir se faire une petite
course à pied de quelques minutes je
suis pas sportif faire du vélo en ville
malheureusement confinement faisant
c'est un petit peu délicat j'ai pu me
déplacer avec mon vélo avec la gauche au
pouvoir ont fait quelques images et vous
montrer quand même en situation réelle
[Musique]
donc les lycées il s'est dit je me suis
vraiment bien baladé avec émoi ce que
sont vraiment super mais vraiment super
c'est que vous ayez accès à ces
informations quand vous vous baladez ces
informations je trouve vraiment mais
vraiment précieuse j'ai accès en
permanence un à batterie restante à
l'heure jacques c'est ici à ma durée
d'exercice depuis combien de temps je
n'en sais depuis mon application et je
monte donc à causer attendant
l'application doit aller voir c'est
vraiment bien là ça fait dix minutes et
38 secondes que je suis parti je connais
ma vitesse actuelle qui est de 0 km
heure et je connais ma vitesse moyenne
ensuite tout se passe ici regarde c'est
là là se tient est tombé là en fait
c'est une caméra tough c'est donc une
caméra time of light qui va pouvoir
reconnaître les mouvements main devant
pour pouvoir changer d'écran quand je
passe la main comme ça hop je change
d'écran au bout du quatrième passage eh
bien ça en est à mon écran et je repasse
et journaux sur mon écran principal
je connais donc ici ma durée ma cadence
et pour afficher votre fréquence
cardiaque
vous pouvez connecter un
cardiofréquencemètre que ce soit une
montre bracelet ou encore une ceinture
distance dénivelé vitesse vitesse
moyenne
c'est une vision tête haute j'ai plein
d'informations et il faut savoir que
jules beau travail à faire évoluer ses
lunettes il ya pouvoir vous affichez
toujours plus de choses
il ya deux parties distinctes ici vous
avez la partie matérielle mais toute la
partie logicielle peut complètement
évolué pour vous apporter de nouveaux
services de nouveaux affichages qui
seront toujours plus adaptée aux
sportifs vos lunettes arrive dans cette
belle boîte là c'est vrai que packaging
est très sympa vous avez toutes les
infos derrière en fait il vous montre
les différents tableaux d'affichage
c'est ce que vous voyez un pourcentage
de batteries les de l'activité les
battements par minute la lure
instantanée distance parcourue dénivelé
positif cumulé la vitesse instantanée la
vitesse moyenne est votre application
mais je vous la monde en quelques
instants alors normalement ici vous avez
7 et 8 dans lequel elle dispose évolué
d'ailleurs votre étui je trouve très
sympa aussi de protection dans lequel
vous pouvez venir les ranger quelques
petits accessoires et je voulais montrer
si dans quelques instants comme on les
sort de la lunette il faut pouvoir à la
nettoyer
il faut pouvoir venir la protéger en la
rangeant dans son étui on a du câblage
pour venir le recharger on a un autre né
notre en but n'est parce que oui si
regardez là par différentes tailles en
fonction de la forme de son nez on n'a
pas tous la même forme donné vous venez
retirer votre nez vous venez surtout
recharger vos lunettes ici en micro usb
grâce à ce petit câble là et de l'autre
côté vous êtes sûr de l'usb un peu plus
standard et en fonction de la forme de
votre nez et bien vous allez utiliser un
embout plutôt qu'un autre petit les
grands d une droit pour tout le monde et
même pour moi
moi je prendre celui là quand vous avez
fini vous remettez votre en bout de nez
à l'intérieur mais faites attention
surtout surtout à ne pas venir bouger la
batterie si pour ne pas voir casser du
lbo a pensé à tous de vrais expertise au
niveau de la lunette pour le sport pour
l'outdoor
ici vous avez des petits caoutchouc
qu'ils vont pas venir tirer les cheveux
ça c'est plutôt cool est vraiment très
très très confortable
on vous prend effectivement par la main
si pour vous montrer comment ça marche
parce que tout le monde n'est pas
forcément hyper à l'aise tout de suite
avec ce typologie de produits qui est
vraiment tout tout tout tout nouveau on
vous explique comment régler on vous
explique comment recharger on vous parle
de votre application on vous montre
comment ça marche en anglais mais
rassurez-vous bien évidemment en
français ici parce que wifi il faut le
prendre du côté français c'est quand
même un peu plus évident est là où
justement ça on sent ce soit un
fabricant de lunettes qui vous fabrique
ce produit et non pas un
bottes de high tech c'est que tout est
pensé vraiment pour les passionnés de
sport regardez vous venez tac met sa
carrière vouloir entrer un fonds pour
être sûr que vos lunettes ne parle
jamais vous seriez bien attacher bien
tenues bien calé en fonction des sports
vous allez faire c'est qu'elle est
derrière votre tête et là croyez moi
vous pouvez y aller skier aussi super
ici c'est que ces lunettes sont imprimés
en france et toute l'électronique gêne
la boîte française qui s'appelle
microoled donc six élus des deux vous
intéresse vous savez vous allez faire
travailler des entreprises françaises
que ce soit le fabricant d'électronique
le fabricant de lunettes qui dit l'une
est connecté d'y connecter à quelque
chose et et s'y connecter à votre
smartphone grâce à une application
active look
cette application on va tenter de se
connecter lunettes les commerçants pas
lui mais ça ne marchera pas
première chose je la lui leurs lunettes
actives book by micro l'aide police
connecte à petit look et ensuite j'ai la
référence du mali m donc là on me
demande de démarrer recherche mes
lunettes elles sont prouvées
j'ai plus qu'appuyé et je me connecte
donc l'ajax et à trois écrans premier
écran deuxième écran troisième écran
pour démarrer ma partie de ce sport j'ai
qu'appuyer ici j'ai un décompte que je
vois apparaître exactement de la même
manière dans mes lunettes et ensuite
j'ai legault et c'est parti mon premier
écran est destiné à la vitesse le
suivant à la distance et le troisième au
battement que j'ai ici mon historique où
je vois tout mon parcours
le temps que j'y ai passé le dénivelé la
distance la vitesse moyenne mal quand
même presque 20 km heure ma cadence et
ensuite j'ai des graphiques sont
vachement intéressante avec ma vitesse
au moment auquel j'étais en train de
pédaler je vois l'altitude et j'ai
ensuite ma progression avec ma distance
donc ça permet vraiment d'avoir un vrai
retour sur mon parcours sur mon
historique
si je veux venir analyser mes
performances après et ensuite j'ai
quelques réglages je peut activer le
capteur de geste la caméra tough la
luminance automatique
est ce le même venir dès qu'elle est mon
écran tel qu'il est projeté dans mes
lunettes je peux ensuite arrêté ma
session en appuyant la chaire au stop ou
une pause comme je le souhaite c'est ici
n'est évidemment une application qui est
disponible sur ios mais il
allemand sur android le seul
inconvénient que vous avez avec vous je
pense que se sera améliorée dans le
temps à venir c'est que vous devez avoir
votre smartphone avec vous notamment
pour avoir le gps ça c'est un petit peu
dommage
il peut être dans un sac à dos il peut
être dans une veine dans une poche de ce
que vous voulez à vous de voir mais pour
l'instant tout cas vous avez à votre
smartphone avec vous mais parce qu'il ya
toujours un mais si vous avez une montre
ou un kotor garmin et bien vous allez
pouvoir les connecter directement à
votre lunette pour vous affranchir de
votre smartphone
si donc les informations directement de
votre montre ou votre compteur qui vont
s'afficher dans vos lunettes vous
n'aurez donc pas besoin d'emmener votre
smartphone avec vous ça c'est aussi une
bonne alternative
j'ai pu remarquer un truc avec mon
casque c'est que en fait lorsque je le
mets comme ça il ya une espèce
d'interférence avec ma caméra tough mes
carnets rate of allez l'adorer il faut
que je passe ma main comme ça pour que
ça me change d'écran sauf qu'ici le
problème c'est que peut-être la
proximité avec mon casque va changer
tout seul l'affichage donc je suis
obligé de poser mon casque un peu plus à
l'arrière alors rien de bien des cônes
en mai un tout petit peu et ça me permet
effectivement à ce moment là de ne plus
avoir ce changement d'écran quand on
oublie ces quelques points on a des
lunettes qui sont vraiment bien qu'ils
surtout viennent vraiment améliorer
l'expérience alors on pourrait se dire
est ce que le fait d'avoir un affichage
ans qu'on fait du sport on fait du vélo
et notamment sur la route parce que ça
peut être dangereux parce que le moment
vous regardez ce qui se passe dans vos
lunettes
eh bien vous ne regardez pas la route
très honnêtement c'est une seconde de
secondes même si effectivement dans
certaines situations de sport où on est
vraiment vraiment concentré sur ce que
vous faites vous jeter un petit coup
d'oeil vous êtes accès à vos
informations et vous êtes tout de suite
concentré sur votre route donc c'est
vraiment un truc extrêmement rassurant
moi qui ne suis pas un sportif qui ne
vais pas courir je fais un peu de vélo
mais j'en fais pas non plus tout le
temps eh bien j'ai vraiment aimé ça j'ai
vraiment aimé pouvoir me balader en
ville tout en connaissant la vitesse
exacte à laquelle je voulais le fait
d'avoir des informations très rapidement
mais je suis un peu frustré parce que je
voudrais aller encore plus loin pour moi
la réalité augmentée c'est super le fit
power des lunettes qui viennent nous
donner toutes ces informations c'est
vraiment génial mais pour un citadin
comme moi tu les prends mon vélo pour
aller me balader et bien j'adorerais
pouvoir avoir je sais pas moi une
liaison avec google maps qui puisse me
guider dans la ville tourne à droite
tourner à gauche sans avoir des
écouteurs de pouvoir juste le voir ça
serait vraiment bien
c'est vraiment un super boulot jules
aussi vous êtes sportif si vous aimez le
sport si vous voulez faire un très beau
cadeau un très beau cadeau à quelqu'un
qui fait beaucoup de sport qui va courir
et qu'il veut des lunettes connectés qui
vraiment branché connectivité faut
vraiment l'être pour ce coup là c'est
eva douane elles sont hyper canon mais
par contre elle ne sont pas destinés à
tout le monde parce que cette petite
perle l'une est connecté coûtent
quasiment 500 euros on est à 499 euros
90 c'est un objet premium
c'est un produit qui est très rare qu'un
tout nouveau que je trouve génial et
surtout ce que font vraiment génial
derrière c'est que ça vienne d'une
entreprise française un lunettier
qu'elle a depuis plus de 150 ans qui
viennent
innover et qui viennent vraiment se
positionner sur un produit qui est une
nouveauté dans le genre du bo va faire
évoluer ses lunettes on aura de plus en
plus de fonctionnalités toujours plus à
destination des sportifs ça on commence
à auvelais la voix et le fait qu'ils
aient deux entreprises françaises qui
collaborent sur ce produit là c'est
vraiment génial
a vous de me dire vous maintenant ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
comment vous les trouvez c'est eva
douanes de jimbo bien intéressante pas
trop dites moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire et ciel vous intéresse
bien évidemment vous ai mis un lien par
la description des gros bisous beaucoup
d'amour et à très vite
ciao
[Musique]